ثمانيه وثلاثون من اجمالي مساحه اليابسه
في العالم تستخدم للزراعه ومع ذلك الامن
الغذائي مهدد بفعل الصراعات والركود
العلمي وتغير المناخ لا حلن شاملا لكن
التكنولوجيا قد تساعد ولو قليلا جعلوا
الزراعه اكثر كفاءه وفاعليه عبر تقنيات
الذكاء الاصطناعي والروبوتات هي الوسيله
في ذلك
مزايا كثيره توفرها الروبوتات الاليه في
الزراعه تعملوا 24 ساعه في اليوم ما يعني
هي فرصه للحصاد في كل الاوقاف صباح الباكر
تحديدا وهو افضل وقت للثمار من حيث النضج
ومحت والماء
الروبوتات تساهم ايضا في قطف المحاصيل فقط
عندما تكون جاهزه ما يقلل من الفاقد ويحسن
من الجوده
ميزه اخرى وهي جمع البيانات عبر اجهزه
الاستشعار
بالتوازي مع الحصاد وهنا يعرف المزارعون
الكميات ومدى جودتها
الروبوت يتم تصميمه بحيث يمكنه التحكم
لقوه عمليات الحصاد وفقا لنوع الثمر
المزروعه بحيث لا تتلفها
القبض ايحتوي ايضا على كاميرا توفر
معلومات حول مسافه الروبوت من الفاكهه
ويمكن لروبوتات ايضا ازاله الاعشاب الضاره
في غضون يوم الى اثنين وهي مهمه تستغرق
اسابيع اذا اجريت يدويا عدا طبعا عن عامل
السرعه ما يعني زياده الامدادات الاجماليه
من الغذاء المشكله الوحيده حتى الان هو ان
الروبوتات فقط تلغي بعض الوظائف لكنها قد
لا تكون مشكله كبيره ان علمنا ان نسبه
اصابه ومرض العمال المزارعين
مرتفعه للغايه بسبب طول ساعات العمل في
ظروفيه مختلفه